ciao a tutti quei tornanti storiche
stesse oggi parliamo degli impatti 3
andiamo ad aggiungere ingredienti
assurdi anche suggeriti da voi allo
style ingredienti che normalmente con
aggiungeresti mai allo slide lasciato in
bella è che se volete vedere altri video
del genere fatemi fare sapere nei
commenti che a segmenti gli argomenti
che allegre e gli attori dovrei
aggiungere allo slide scrivetevi tutto
nei commenti e ora siete pronti
utilizziamo stupito quello di sly
dovrete indovinare se funzionerà quindi
se non ci fossimo funzionerà allora il
primo a mio primo a mettere la colla poi
andiamo a mettere la panna al posto
della schiuma da barba
non vi preoccupate perché in questa
panna che si ascolta perché sono andati
momenti cyrano time blocchi con la panna
invece la stima da barba scrivetemi ora
nei commenti vediamo chi indovina chi è
qui
[Musica]
dentro o mostra
chi buttare tutta la bomboletta ma ho
paura che poi magari toglie tutto ecco
quali sembra scrivo da barba
speriamo che funzioni la sentenza è
molto più dannosa ovviamente qualche
modo ma si attiverà puzza di gorgonzola
che colore lidia voliamo bruno pugliese
non ho mai provato questo colore ancora
proviamo con certezze evento che bello
questo colore perché poi non andrà a
male va a butta una sorta di
celeste chiaro
ok siete pronti proviamo ora ad
attivarlo e scopriamo se a farla
funziona per fare lo slime che vada con
la soluzione barletti e la polvere di
corno sembra molto liquido per ora però
non diamoci per vinti continuiamo ad
attivarlo vediamo che guarda te sembra
che qualcosa stia succedendo è un
pochino più solido però non sono sicura
se si sta attivando proprio ad
aggiungere altro bicarbonato abbondato
un bel po
forse qualcosa sta succedendo ragazzi
non ci credo perché solidificando porta
sul 8 zio che sai come la consistenza
ragazzi
sono quasi che i ragazzi non ci posso
credere si è formato ora proviamo a
tirarlo fuori un po messi toso oddio
vediamo un po qual è la differenza con
la schiuma da barba
allora sentiamo ai suoni allora le
differenze sono che come potete vedere
rimane molto più liquido l'anpana non va
a gonfiarlo molto e sembra un po sciolto
nonostante abbia messo molto attivatore
quindi incredibile non ci posso credere
ma ha funzionato
sentiamo che odore ha la riforma ti
indicherò otto date a questo primo time
con la panna rimettere i commenti ok
passiamo al prossimo slam ok ragazzi
con ingredienti trani ho già messo la
colla eclatanti amato aggiungere prima
dobbiamo attivare un po prima di
aggiungervi stand o poi cade tutto
quindi andiamo a scegliere il colore
tanto colore si chiama sifone
vediamo un po io forse ho capito
processo e verde
no ma perché l'hanno chiamato il tipo
mettete anche tutta volta il verde mi ha
imbrogliato però non è molto forte come
perde aggiungo un altro colore
in quel blu così magari essere un per te
acqua abbiamo che colore dai una sorta
di verde acqua che ne dite meglio del
verde nel cielo perfetto bravo e troppo
uguale anche poco prima aggiungo
l'arancione così non sono troppo simili
non so di che cosa diventerà un po
troppo che sta succedendo questo
colorante si sta rifiutando vediamo di
che colore diventa mi sembra uguale a
prima
aggiungiamo un altro colore un'ora che
cosa aggiungiamo oddio questo è
fortissimo ok ora dovrebbe cambiare
colore è il lime carino ok mi piace così
dai ora posso attivarlo un pochino e poi
aggiungiamo l'altro ingrediente strano
allora eccoci qua lo slide quasi attivo
va da aggiungere l'ingrediente segreto
che la pena
spero che faccia una sorta di
live vediamo trovando sembra che sta
passando la ciotola di cereali ok
dovrebbe bastare
proviamo a mischiare stranissimo sistema
in blu mondo bostrom sa bene devo dire
spero che non solo dà lo slime paoli
alza prende tutte
vediamo un po fa un po di suoni cranchi
non tantissimi prodotti giungere ancora
un po
[Applauso]
suoni crunchy incredibile così meglio
delle palline note fantastico funziona
veramente non so che ci sono i grassi
questa allora cosa ne pensate di questo
sliven fatto con la pena ha messo lì
piacciono tantissimo
scrivetemi nei commenti cosa ne pensate
miss e vivificata indietro prima che
uscisse se secondo voi usciva spero che
la gente titolo spesso e ora siete
pronti a vedere l'ultimo ingrediente
furto che l'ultimo ingrediente segreto
andiamo innanzitutto come sempre a
mettere la colla poi mettiamo il
colorato questo che il colorante mettere
utilizziamo il giallo eccolo qua
vediamo vediamo se nicolari bene bello
anche questa di moda si parlò un pochino
per fare in modo che lascia ingrediente
si unisca e amalgami bene ok ragazzi ora
il momento di ingredienti tra un segreto
che cos'è da il burro questo e burro
vegetale perché non mangiamo male un
animale mangiamo il burro vegetale
quindi margarina riusciremo a fare
butterfly un master plan con il vero
bauder vegetale
vediamo ok ecco quale prendo un bel po
spero che si sciolga stand o pensa che è
impossibile amalgamarli che finiva un po
se riusciamo a farlo sciogliere nello
slam e come sta scegliendo un bene si
praticamente già assolto
se qualche gruppo sembra che stia
funzionando come sarà poi la consistenza
vediamo mi ha madato si parla
[Applauso]
siamo quasi certi ci siamo ecco qua non
ci posso credere che uscito anche questo
sembra quasi classi e è uscito super
morbido comunque sembra più un trinci
slang che un butters lime ora sentiamo i
suoni
[Applauso]
super soffice
spalmabile non fa molti suoni quel costo
riguarda le bollicine per of assumono i
pochi
allora fatemi sapere che su tutti
butters lime avena slime crunchy oppure
panna slime scrivete nei commenti quale
vi è piaciuto di più
fatevi pure sapere nei commenti quali
altri ingredienti volete che mettere lo
slime per vedere se funzionano e adesso
timbriche a questo video se volete
vedere un altro episodio e io ero vi
lascio con quattro katz linee su cui
cliccare per vedere i prossimi video
design challenge clicca su quello che
preferite e buona visione
ciao